[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
locales et régionales et sur tv5 monde
avec la participation de la presse
quotidienne régionale
voici les titres de l'actualité la
vaccination est en marche
coup d'accélérateur pour la campagne de
vaccination en france après les
polémiques sur sa lenteur le personnel
soignant et les personnes âgées sont
prioritaires reportage dans un instant
en occitanie le monde de la culture est
fermée théâtres cinémas et autres musées
resteront fermés jusqu'à nouvel ordre
la date du 20 janvier un temps espéré
par le monde de la culture est désormais
repoussée par le gouvernement les
réactions à suivre dans ce journal
un grand comédien et metteur en scène
robert hossein vous le savez est décédé
la semaine dernière
saleen d'adoption vittel dans les vosges
lui a rendu un bel hommage que nous
regarderons en images tout à l'heure
enfin vous le verrez pour terminer ce
journal de belles images des ballets de
monaco qui malgré la pandémie continue
de fonctionner je vous le disais dans
les titres la vaccination s'accélère sur
fond de polémique sur son rythme jugé
trop lent par certains la priorité a été
donnée aux personnels hospitaliers et
aux personnes âgées à l'hôpital de
prades est dans les pyrénées-orientales
bien connu du premier ministre il en
était le maire
douze patients de l'unité soins longue
durée ont accepté de recevoir le
traitement
tous les détails avec la chaîne vient
occitanie sur place les premiers vaccins
contre la copie de dix neuf ont été
effectués en occitanie ce lundi à
l'hôpital de prades dans les pyrénées
orientales 12 patients de l'unité de
soins longue durée ont accepté de
recevoir le traitement
ça s'est très bien passé rien de gentils
des gourdins a parlé j'ai dit aller et
ira mais mr ce n'est pas du tout à la
machinerie en plus des patients les
soignants de plus de 50 ans peuvent
aussi recevoir le vaccin depuis lundi le
docteur patrice gimbert et le premier
praticiens de santé à avoir reçu la
vaccination dans les pyrénées-orientales
il souhaite montrer l'exemple et
encourager ses patients à faire de même
puis exposée à tous les jours donc c'est
normal que je me fasse vacciner
et puis c'est un acte de protection pour
pour la société coiffer celle d'un acte
civique je suis
un pro de la vaccination depuis est
toujours en fait c'est même le fait
qu'on se pose la question qui met un
petit peu avant lundi 4 janvier seuls
350 de doses ont été administrées en
france l'hexagone est d'ailleurs très
critiqué pour la lenteur de sa politique
de vaccination mais la couverture
vaccinale va s'intensifier en occitanie
cent mille personnes âgées et
professionnels de santé doivent être
vaccinées d'ici le début du mois de
février
nous allons monter en puissance
évidemment au cours de la semaine et
tout au long du mois de janvier avec
l'objectif d'avoir vacciné l'ensemble
des personnes âgées en établissement au
début du mois de février et d'avoir
vacciner le maximum de professionnels de
santé de plus de 50 ans au cours de ce
mois de janvier puisque ensuite nous
souhaitons passer début février à
l'opération de vaccination des personnes
âgées de plus de 75 ans à domicile et
ensuite des personnes âgées de plus de
65 ans preuve de cette volonté
d'accélérer mardi chaque point
départemental de vaccination de la
région sera approvisionné en doses le
gouvernement l'a annoncé cette semaine
vous le savez le monde de la culture
fait grise mine
les musées et autres cinémas ne sont pas
prêts de rouvrir leurs portes
regardez quelques réactions après celle
du 15 décembre nouvelle désillusion pour
les acteurs du monde culturel qui espère
ouvrir le 20 janvier prochain en raison
des données sanitaires actuelles musées
cinémas ou encore théâtre vont devoir
rester fermé pour l'instant c'est ce
qu'a annoncé le porte-parole du
gouvernement le 1er janvier on a prévu
joue à partir du 1 janvier une série de
dates parce qu'on nous a quand même
parlé du 20 janvier c'était la date la
plus lointaine soi-disant mais j'ai peur
que malheureusement ce soit une date de
revoyure une réouverture tant espéré
qu'ils n'arrivent pas et des dates sans
arrêt repoussé qui ne permettent pas aux
acteurs locaux de se projeter et les
attentes des déclarations claires de la
part du gouvernement
moi je préférerais qu'on me dise écoutez
vous payez pas gelé jusqu'au 1er mars
vous pouvez pas jouer jusqu'au 1er avril
parce qu'on s'organiserait autrement
alors que là en réalité on ne peut pas
s'organiser c'est de 10 jours en huit
jours qu'on prévient
dictateur donc tous les dix jours ont
leurs écrits bon bah désolé mais là on
va pas pouvoir jouer les acteurs du
monde culturel comprennent que
l'épidémie ne permet pas d'avoir une
date fixe de reprise
ils se tiennent prêts à rouvrir leurs
portes et attendent le feu vert du
gouvernement
vous nous avez fait confiance au mois de
mai lorsque nous avons ouvert
faites nous confiance nous avons pris
les mesures nécessaires pour permettre
de travailler dans de bonnes conditions
nous sommes vraiment utile nous
souhaitons vivement pouvoir accompagner
nos concitoyens et obtenir d'eux vous
rapidement une ouverture les
établissements culturels n'ont pas
ouvert leurs portes depuis octobre
dernier et l'on repart de la météo dans
ce grand jt des territoires l'hiver est
bien là et cela faisait longtemps qu'ils
n'étaient pas arrivés dans la loire les
températures sont basses et la neige est
là également pour les habitants de la
région
cette neige fait pourtant chaud au coeur
un reportage de nos confrères sur place
de tl7 télé loire 7 depuis le 1er
janvier les températures n'ont pas
dépassé la barre symbolique des 0° le
froid commence à s'installer trouve que
ça fait du bien moi j'aime bien j'aime
bien l'hiver jamais revoir les quatre
saisons donc bah ça rassure aussi
d'avoir des hivers aussi proche qu'avant
donc moi je suis contente et de la neige
il faut faire gaffe à être équipés bon
je retrouve un petit peu avec un climat
normal de chez nous quoi ça s'appelle en
janvier qu'ils fassent phrase si chaud
que ça plus dur travail et de voir là
tout de suite mais on n'est pas habitué
mais bon c'est normal dans le massif du
pilat ici il fait moins cinq degrés et
un épais brouillard recouvre le décor
d'habitude on peut voir derrière moi un
magnifique paysage
aujourd'hui on ne voit rien la neige
aussi reste fixé au panneau elle est
gelée complètement et sur la route
attention parce que le verglas
persistent encore sur les routes jusqu'à
-8 degrés le sel est déversée pour faire
fondre le verglas et dans le cas d'un
hiver rude 25 mille tonnes de sel sont
réservés pour l'entretien des routes
ça faisait longtemps que ce n'était pas
arrivé et là on est sur les deux
semaines qui viennent on a des
prévisions météo qui sont
pas très bonne et qui laisse penser
qu'effectivement les conditions peuvent
être difficiles donc on aura sans doute
un hiver plus rigoureux au moins que
l'hiver dernier quand on est à
température négative entre 0 et - 7 - 8
on le sait elle permet effectivement de
faire fondre la neige est de faire
fondre la glace quand c'est du verglas
vous l'aurez compris les routes du
département de la loire sont largement
praticable mais ici dans la montée du
col de la république
les équipements spéciaux sont
obligatoires comme l'indiquent le
panneau juste derrière moi c'est le cas
aussi pour le col du béal et celui de la
loge la nouvelle année commence bien
vous allez le voir pour les
automobilistes amiénois le stationnement
gratuit à partir de 17h30 en centre
ville est désormais officielle cette
mesure expérimentale pour l'instant qui
vise à redynamiser les commerces de
centre-ville va durer six mois
alors comment est elle accueillie par
les amiénois directement sur place par
les commerçants les équipes de la chaîne
wéo la chaîne de la voix du nord vous
raconte cela sur place regarder se garer
gratuitement centre ville d'amiens à
partir de 17h30 c'est désormais possible
depuis samedi dernier les amiénois
peuvent profiter sereinement des
commerces dans les rues d'amiens
la nouvelle est pour la plupart saluer
mais certains s'interrogent encore
personnellement je ne suis pas je vois
intéressés en ce sens que je prends le
bus et je trouve que c'est la solution
la meilleure encore parce que 17h30
arrêter le temps de sa laisse très peu
de temps ça va faire du bien aux
commerçants qui ont beaucoup souffert
pour certaines enseignes du centre-ville
le contexte sanitaire et les
confinements successifs ont été fatales
régis de grease et cavistes en centre
ville d'amiens pour lui la gratuité du
stationnement à partir de 17h30
oui mais il faudrait aller plus loin
est-ce que ça va pas faire un effet
ventouse
c'est dire que les personnes habitant en
centre-ville forcément auprès de tenter
aussi de se garer plus près voilà et ça
c'est l'expérience qui nous lira mais
globalement moi je pense que c'est une
excellente mesure on a franchement
besoin de ça ce qui serait bien si par
la suite ça serait éventuellement rendre
la journée la première journée des
soldes gratuite également et le samedi
le premier samedi des soldes ça pourrait
être une grande aide pour les
commerçants du centre ville le
stationnement gratuit était une promesse
de campagne de la municipalité en place
avec un objectif
redynamiser le centre-ville et soutenir
les commerçants difficile pour l'heure
de connaître les effets de cette mesure
en phase de test alors pas question
d'aller plus loin pour le moment on va
faire des comptages on va voir si sa vie
bien si c'est opportun si ça n'amène pas
non plus trop de voitures ventouses tout
est attestée 1 il faut vraiment essayer
pour être sûr d'efficacité la gratuité
du stationnement en centre ville à
partir de 17h30 durera six mois en cas
de couvre-feu à 18 heures la mairie
assure que le dispositif pourra être
prolongé bonjour michel picaud comme
chaque semaine notre rendez vous éco
région avec vous et cette semaine vous
allez nous parler d'une start up
française qui grandit bien vite et qui
est présente pratiquement sur tous nos
territoires et également à
l'international
il s'agit de tout gone to go c'est une
appli anti gaspillage alimentaire
bonjour sert il
bonjour à toutes et à tous to god togo
c'est un phénomène né en france en
région parisienne en 2010 est le concept
lutter contre le gaspillage alimentaire
la méthode nouer des partenariats avec
des magasins alimentaires boulangerie
pâtisserie supermarché même des hôtels
dont les petits déjeuners ont été
souvent surdimensionnés et finissent à
la poubelle
l'idée est donc de constituer des
paniers avec des produits justement qui
ne sont pas vendus et vendre ses paniers
à prix avantageux et pour trouver des
acheteurs consommateurs ils ont créé une
application mobile de mise en relation
entre ces commerçants et les
consommateurs
le succès colossal en france et donc un
ce pays aujourd'hui et même à new york
et boston en 2020 ils ont évité de jeter
15 millions de repas grâce à leur panier
côté effectif dans notre pays ils sont
passés de 7 en 2010 est à 90 aujourd'hui
et ils sont six ans en europe
enfin ils se sont engagés aussi sur les
dates de limitation de consommation des
produits afin de mieux gérer les flux de
cette nourriture pas forcément en fin de
vie la france vous le savez gaspillé
près de 10
millions de tonnes de produits
alimentaires et sur ses 10 millions 1,2
concentre de la nourriture encore
consommable la lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire c'est très
tendance et même une prise de conscience
de la part des consommateurs
je pense qu'on n'a pas fini d'entendre
parler de cette entreprise de good to go
merci michel picaud et rendez vous dans
un nouveau grand jt des territoires pour
la rubrique écorégions tout à fait autre
chose dans l'actualité maintenant
direction les yvelines ou la gendarmerie
la préfecture et le monde équestre se
sont réunis fin décembre pour acter un
nouveau protocole de protection des
équidés un moyen d'anticiper les actes
malveillants faite aux chevaux suite aux
nombreuses mutilation recensés en france
ces derniers mois les précisions
d'eléonore sinoquet et de nicolas landry
pour tv 78 sur place vigilance et guider
c'est le nom de la convention qui a été
signée mercredi 30 décembre dans les
écuries du poste à cheval de saint nom
la bretèche entre le monde équestre
l'état et la gendarmerie
objectif assurer la protection des
chevaux après la vague de mutilation
d'équidés de ces derniers mois c'est une
première nationale et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est de voir la tombe
la conjugaison des efforts de tous le
secteur privé des centres équestres des
éleveurs des militaires avec la
gendarmerie nationale la gendarmerie à
chaud la garde républicaine
cette convention vise à créer un réseau
départemental des changes et de
solidarité entre forces de l'ordre et
monde équestre
pour ce faire 15 référent et quittant
seront répartis sur le territoire
i'm all ce sera emma bataillon le rôle
en fait c'est de faire le contact entre
les différents acteurs donc notamment
gendarmerie pour faire remonter
l'information le plus vite possible et
agir en cas de en cas d'événement ce que
l'on ne cède pas bien sûr les yvelines
n'ont pas été choisies au hasard pour
être le premier territoire a signé ce
nouveau protocole de protection quinze
mille chevaux et plus de 800
propriétaires c'est le premier
département équestre d'île de france et
il comporte aussi deux unités de
gendarmes à cheval
les missions de ces deux unités sont
assez classique ça nous permet encore
une fois donc de faire ou du contact du
renseignement avec la population
et puis
damman donc d'avoir des relations très
particulières avec le monde du cheval du
manière globale donc les centres
équestres les haras c'est beaucoup plus
simple parce que les gens viennent
beaucoup plus nous voir ils nous donnent
beaucoup de renseignements qui ne
n'aurais pas forcément donné un véhicule
gendarmerie en plus des 15 référent et
quittant un guide va aussi être diffusé
et des panonceaux affiché pour aller
encore plus loin dans la sécurité
janvier est en théorie un mois avec un
peu moins d'alcool pour beaucoup d'entre
nous qui ont pu en abuser pendant les
fêtes
voici donc ce que donnent les bières
artisanales sans alcool elle offre les
mêmes plaisirs qu'une bonne bière elles
ont toutes les qualités requises la
couleur la densité l'amertume et le goût
et le tout pour moi d'un degré d'alcool
telegrenoble
les a testées pour nous regarder elles
sont à boire sans modération les bières
grenobloise edmonson sans alcool blonde
blanches brunes d'arc ou ip à l offre
les mêmes plaisirs qu'une bonne bière
artisanale
elles ont toutes les qualités requises
couleurs densité amertume et gouf le
tout sous les 1 degré c'est bien sans
alcool s'adresse aux amateurs de bière
en premier lieu qui ont envie de
maîtriser leur consommation d'alcool en
fait ce n'est pas forcément une bière
pour les femmes enceintes comme on peut
penser la bière sans alcool a quand même
une image très ringarde
on a voulu la mettre au goût du jour la
microbrasserie edmond et la première
brasserie artisanale française dédiée
100 % à la bière sans alcool avec son
procédé unique tenu secret elle obtient
des bières sous les 1 degré qui sont non
filtrée et non pasteurisé bonne bière
sans alcool c'est le même principe
qu'une bière avec alcool sauf que on en
rêve pas l'alcool comme dans le système
industriel
on essaie de produire le moins d'alcool
possible donc il ya toujours des débuts
de fermentation sinon c'est pas de la
bière les qualités requises sont
effectivement pour nous en tout cas ce
les bulles le goût de céréales demande
donc des malts et un oubli nage aussi
assez maîtrisée du haut de ses 3 ans
edmond produit aujourd'hui 50
hectolitres par an et de nouvelles
recettes sont déjà dans les tuyaux une
bière blanche orties rhubarbe et une
bière est la courge
nous partons maintenant sur les traces
de la meilleure galette des rois une
tradition dans nos régions en ce mois de
janvier pour la région bretagne c'est
alain le meunier du département d'ille
et vilaine qui remporte le prix c'est
une rencontre et une dégustation qu'on
vous propose maintenant avec les équipes
de tvr sur place à rennes
ce matin la file d'attenté s'allonge
devant l'atelier boulanger à saint
jacques de la lande
beaucoup de curieux venus goûter à la
nouvelle attraction locale la meilleure
galette des rois d'ille et vilaine on ne
la trouve qu'ici dans la boulangerie de
christophe et tiphaine roignant et son
succès ne faiblit pas nous l'avons déjà
goûté la jungle d'en prendre une autre
et elle c'est vrai quelle excellente
belle consistance bien dorées sur le
dessus avec une patte pas trop peut être
surtout pas à 40 du tout celui qui a mis
au point la recette gagnante c'est alain
lemonnier boulangers pâtissiers
expérimenté il travaille depuis un mois
à l'atelier boulanger etc présentés au
concours de la meilleure galette grâce
aux encouragements de christophe son
employeur ce dernier était aux premières
loges pour suivre ses exploits pendant
quinze jours il a fait que ça et puis ça
a payé
on a fait beaucoup d'essais et pour le
résultat qu'on connaît donc c'était un
vrai plaisir
un vrai vrai plaisir de savoir qu'il
avait fini premier qu'on avait fini
premier même si c'est vrai que les tout
le tout le mérite lui appartient on a
laminé le feuilletage on a trouvé la
bonne épaisseur
on va passer au détail âge pour
participer au concours
alain a dû présenter une galette à la
frangipane de 30 cm de diamètre
une taille importante rendant la cuisson
délicate créatif
il s'est aussi longuement entraînés à la
réalisation de motifs destinés à la
décoration
je me suis entraîné à faire des dessins
pleins de fois le dessin la main avant
de le reproduire sur la pâte
mais c'est vrai la cuisson c'était pour
moi c'était là le plus gros challenge à
trouver c'était la cuisson parce que
pour avoir un produit qu à coeur et
passés sur les bords
c'était le problème l'année prochaine
alain lemonnier fera à son tour partie
du jury
comme tous gagnants du concours on
connaît bien entendu tous le vin de
bordeaux réputée dans le monde entier et
bien désormais il y aura le whisky de
bordeaux produit de a à z dans le
département de la gironde harbert moon
et la première distillerie à sortir un
whisky 100% girondins depuis quelques
semaines les premières bouteilles de cet
alcool sont mises sur le marché
les détails avec ce reportage de télé7
la chaîne du groupe
s'il reste à bordeaux regarder
c'est dans ce monde care de la seconde
guerre mondiale situe à 200 mètres de la
base sous marine de bordeaux qui est
produit moon arbres ce whisky 100%
girondins a été créé par deux bordelais
est à 7 ans jean philippe bélanger yves
médina se sont lancé le défi de produire
un whisky ou toutes les étapes de
fabrication seront réalisés dans le
département en 2017
ils touchent enfin leur rêve du doigt
pour la première fois des céréales de
l'orge et du maïs produit sur l'île
pâtira située sur l'estuaire de la
gironde sont brassés maltais et
distillées ici et des alambics qui
servent à produire cet alcool sont de
fabrication béglaise et c'est un
oenologue miguel patxi qui veillent à
leur bon fonctionnement
toutes les étapes sont importantes bien
sûr mais la distillation et l'alambic
dans lequel louise qui est distillée va
donner une identité
le dise il a obtenu prend ensuite la
direction du bon coeur pour être affiné
ce sont d'anciennes bail de vins rouges
bordelais de sauternes issus de grands
châteaux girondins qui servent à son
élevage le distillat il passera trois
ans durée légale pour pouvoir être
commercialisé sous le nom de whisky ce
bâtiment est un ancien réservoir à
carburant de 4 millions de litres il a
été construit par les allemands pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale pour
alimenter les sous marins de la base
bordelaise il n'a jamais été utilisé
comme tel c'est blanc mesurant 6 mètres
d'épaisseur nous sommes dans un endroit
construit par les allemands donc avec
une une qualité de construction on peut
dire indestructible puisque c'est
construits à l'épreuve des bombes et ça
permet d'avoir
une amplitude thermique certes qui
existent mais qui et je dirai avec
beaucoup d'inertie et de lenteurs qui
est très très favorable un beau
vieillissement de nos fruits si les
créateurs de mode harper's pousse même
l'expérience du whisky 100% girondins
jusqu'à son paroxysme des algues le
varech récoltés sur les plages du
département servent à fumer certaines
céréales avant leur brassage moon
harbour produit à l'heure actuelle 30
mille bouteilles de whisky girondins par
an ses créateurs souhaitent que ces
productions atteint 80 nicolas duel dans
quelques années
et puis dans ce camp jt des territoires
un hommage amical à robert hossein
homme de cinéma et de théâtre disparu
vous le savez il ya quelques jours sa
ville d'adoption vittel dans les vosges
lui a rendu un hommage cette semaine
avant un hommage national qui lui sera
rendu mi janvier
regardez ce reportage des équipes
devient vosges sur place je ne peux
qu'espérer de tout niveau que tout à
coup une prise de conscience enfin des
complices
tout à coup
respect des religions des races de
tourments ce discours humaniste et
oecuménique ne verra pas 2021 en tous
les cas pas dans la bouche de robert
hossein qui s'était éteint le 31
décembre dans une clinique à
essey-lès-nancy au lendemain de son 93e
anniversaire un décès pallier aux
coronavirus contrairement à ce qui était
dit dans un premier temps a tenu à faire
savoir à la fp sa veuve qu'on dise pas
tout qui avait choisi de vivre avec son
époux dans leur maison vite éloize
vittel où un registre de condoléances a
été mise à disposition de la population
en mairie c'est un vraie vie tellement
tout à fait parce qu'il avait su se
fondre dans la population était fois ce
prix peut dire maintien il elle arrive à
côté de nous sans faire de bruit sans
esclandre grand bonhomme un grand
bonhomme citoyen d'honneur de la ville
qu'il a découverte dans les années 80 et
où il s'est donc installée
progressivement au point de vouloir en
faire sa dernière de ne vous savez cette
première ambassade heures de vittel donc
j'ai vu ce qu'ont porté sur paris j'ai
vu ce qu'ont porté au delà des
frontières
vittel était quelque chose pour lui et
pourquoi
oui effectivement je pense qu'il est
tombé amoureux de la ville
il était très attaché l'ancien maire qui
la met bouloumié et et en fait ça lui
permettait de préparer ses spectacles et
de travailler sereinement dans un cadre
enchanteur et paisible pour lui de son
vrai nom abraham oc enough fils d'un
compositeur d'origine iranienne et d'une
comédienne louise moldave robert hossein
aura marqué de son empreinte le cinéma
et du théâtre en france et bien au delà
c'est une carrière exceptionnelle parce
que parce qu'il a tourné avec tous les
metteurs en scène les grands metteurs en
scène il a tourné avec tous les acteurs
et les actrices de sa génération il
avait des souvenirs absolument
incroyable parce que il avait rencontré
chaplin il ya encore peu de temps il me
parlait de rita hayworth d'un regard
nerfs de marlène donc c'est tout le
monde du cinéma et du spectacle qui il
représentait avant un hommage national
qui devrait être rendu courant janvier à
paris les obsèques de robert hossein
auront lieu dans la stricte intimité ce
mercredi après midi à vittel où il sera
inhumé selon son souhait la municipalité
sa veuve candice patou ont prévu d'y
travailler de concert une fondation et
un musée à sa mémoire verront sans doute
également le jour dans la cité thermale
voilà robert hossein aurait sans doute
aimé cela nous partons dans la
principauté de monaco où malgré la crise
sanitaire les représentations du ballet
de monte-carlo continue une chorégraphie
signée jean christophe maillot
accompagnés par l'orchestré
philarmonique de monaco
regardez ces images et c'est un
reportage de josé sacré pour la chaîne
monaco info
[Musique]
j'ai un tel respect pour l'oeuvre
originale qui à mes yeux ne peut être
dense et que dans des compagnies avec
une homogénéité de danseurs absolument
parfaite c'est à dire opéra de paris
ballet royal de londres moscou
là où les danseurs sont élevées depuis
leur enfance dans une esthétique
particulière et du coup quand on en met
30 ou 40 sur scène on a le même type de
corps le même type de d'articulation le
même type de technique et du coup on a
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
harmonieux mais dans une compagnie comme
la nôtre à monaco où j'ai 25
nationalités des gens qui viennent du
monde entier avec des peaux blanches
noires mates
il ya une obligation à repenser une
écriture chorégraphique qui correspond à
l'outil qui est celui des baleines au
poker
à
c'est une pièce pour moi qui me plaît
beaucoup que je trouve je me lance un
peu des fleurs je la trouve courageuse
dans le le risque que j'ai pu prendre
pour adapter à l'outil qui celui des
ballets de monte carlo une oeuvre
emblématique comme celle-là et pouvoir
le partager avec le public on retrouve
en la musique de tchaïkovski là d'autant
plus avec plaisir puisque c'est kazuki
yamada qui dirige je dois dire qu'il est
outre la qualité de l'orchestré la
couleur magnifique de l'orchestré il est
en plus tellement à l'ecoute de ma
propre demande
[Musique]
ado district jean yanne
voilà merci d'avoir suivi cette édition
du grand jt des territoires sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales et sur tv5
monde
on se retrouve pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]